des bleus en février ben c'est possible
et semble-t-il c'est ce que nous dit
notre invité ce soir si on décide de
chacun chacune de manger en fonction des
saisons et de prévoir les mois d'hiver
au lieu d'acheter des fruits et légumes
importés du mexique ou de la californie
bien congeler les fruits et légumes
peuvent être très bon jean martin
fortier et le jardiniers maraîchers
qu'on connaît très très bien coauteur
avec marie-claude lortie de l'avenir est
dans le champ publié il ya quelques
semaines bonsoir jean marc fauroux
l'objectif de ce livre donc c'est de
nous dire que 12 mois par année
on peut se nourrir localement de son
jardin de son potager entre autres entre
autres entre autres c'est l'une des
solutions et on a d'autres
l'exercice c'était avec marie-claude
lortie de donner des solutions pour les
gens qui s'intéressent à cette question
là et aussi brisé plusieurs mythes comme
par exemple parce que manger des bleuets
c'est possible au mois de février là
c'est oui ils sont congelés ils font
d'excellentes art
c'est magnifique donc et tout plein de
solutions d'astuces pour arriver à
manger en saison surtout dans l'île ce
qu'on a voulu faire aussi c'est
expliquer aux gens pourquoi c'est si
important
puis pourquoi que l'avenir est dans le
champ c'est que c'est une opportunité
importante pour notre économie au québec
aussi de vraiment se concentrer sur une
agriculture locale que les gens courent
à juin qui se développe de plus en plus
et donc c / les mois par exemple vous
dites l'épinard au mois de décembre le
chou vert frisé au mode janvier le
bleuet en février mais pour réfléchir
sur comment prévoir comment planifier
comme à conserver justement les légumes
en même temps on a l'impression que
toute notre chaîne d'approvisionnement
et tout notre fonctionnement alimentaire
ne fonctionne plus comme celui et la
chaîne traditionnelle non mais je
devrais pas dire traditionnel c'est une
[ __ ] au contraire la schl à la chaîne
moderne actuelle mais elle aussi a le
des changements
qui doit s'opérer parce que dans le fond
il faut pas que le rôle puis la
responsabilité revient uniquement sur le
citoyen mangeant lui un rôle important à
jouer mais c'est chaud son choix en
impact mais où ils s'approvisionnent eux
aussi ont un rôle civique a joué un
geste à poser pour dire nous on veut
s'approvisionner localement puis il n'y
a pas de logique qu'en janvier en
épicerie au québec on offre des fraises
qui viennent la californie on devrait
avoir un moment dans l'année où on
célèbre ce qu'on a ce qu'on fait bien
ici qu'on célèbre la fraise en saison qu
on la consomme au bon moment mais au
delà de jus ce qui est bien ou ce qui
est mal c'est plus de dire il existe
plein d'alternative plusieurs façons de
faire autrement avec des conséquences
qui peuvent être très porteuse pour
l'avenir de l'agriculture au québec est
donc dans ce livre c'est une célébration
justement de l'alimentation bio local
c'est aussi un rappel de ce que vous
dites depuis plusieurs années c'est à
dire qu'on peut cultiver autrement on
peut avoir une autre approche
depuis plusieurs années on voit un
mouvement biologique de jeunes de jeunes
fermiers de jeunes infirmières également
le jeune maraîcher maraîchères et vous
rappliquent
il ya beaucoup d'entravés ces jeunes là
présentement des entraves réglementaire
gouvernementale
ça c'est la moins bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'en effet pour faire une écriture qui
est écologique pour faire une écriture
de proximité dans les légumes un peu
dans les viandes beaucoup plus il ya
plusieurs règlements qui justement qui
empêche l'entrepreneuriat qui empêche le
démarchage efficace pour pour que sa
culture le soient de plus en plus
pérenne
l'écho tonnes tandis coton notamment
avec les yeux fair milk sanction est
impossible à trouver au québec ou
presque on pourrait nommer plein exemple
sauf que la bonne nouvelle c'est que
présentement le gouvernement actuel avec
le ministre actuel il ya une ouverture
qui est sans précédent où il ya vraiment
des gestes sont posés des politiques qui
vont être changés pour encourager cette
agriculture la part de monsieur les
montants guy noves quoi à quoi pense
mais on va revoir
probablement tout ce qui est
morcellement des terres pour pouvoir non
non les rendre disponibles pour le
développement mais peut-être pour des
plus petits projets agricoles ça je sais
que c'est un dossier qui avance les à
travailler même avec le gouvernement
écoute moi j'ai un travail plus
d'éducation
donc moi je n'ai jamais eu j'aime mieux
travailler avec avec les gens qui vont
pousser ses idées au niveau politique
mais c'est pas moi c'est pas ma tasse de
thé d'être au niveau politique mais ça
c'en est un exemple après ça t il tout
le travail qui est fait sur les
abattages les petits abattoirs vont être
rendues possibles il ya des projets
pilotes encore toutes les choses les
problèmes sur lequel moi je me suis
buter dans les dernières années
pour la première fois j'entends que des
solutions qui vont être mises de l'avant
pour avancer
ça c'est le fun parce que dans le fond
l'entrepreneuriat puis le tout le
l'esprit en ce moment qui souffre mais
il faut faut le célébrer et des jeunes
qui veulent faire l'agriculture il ya
des gens qui font de la culture qui est
belle il faut encourager ce riz est ce
que vous aller jusqu'à remettre en
question la gestion de l'offre
non moi je veux pas jusque-là remettre
la gestion de l'offre c'est paul dossier
sur lequel moi je me penche mais je
pense que la gestion de l'offre doit pas
nuire à la petite agriculture
donc il faut trouver les bons réglages
il faut les changements qui doivent être
faites soit faite mais il faut que faut
qu'une agriculture à échelle humaine une
agriculture qui est très
entrepreneuriale qui est une agriculture
d'occupation du territoire soit soit
possible pour que plus de gens puissent
s'établir à la campagne puis rebelles
revaloriser nos territoires donc ça il
faut que tout cela fonctionne pour
permettre la chance à des nouveaux
agriculteurs de s'établir et comment
réduire les pesticides réduire également
les ogm dans le livre vous indiquer
qu'on est passé de 8 à 81 2% à 20 25 ans
du pourcentage de chant où l'on retrouve
du maïs ogm mais la première chose qui
le livre l'expliquent bien je crois que
les gens doivent se conscientiser se
responsabiliser ceux
les méfaits des pesticides pour leur
propre santé et comme société surtout
nous au québec on à socialiser
finalement la santé il y aurait des
gestes politiques à poser pour pour se
protéger quand il compte les méfaits des
pesticides dans livre c'est bien
documenté les ogm c'est la même chose de
l'autre côté tout une agriculture bio
une écriture écologique qui est déjà en
marche avec beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui
travaille dans ce sens là je crois que
le citoyen doit faire le geste
d'encourager cette agriculture pour
qu'elle puisse se développer pour
qu'elle puisse être plus présents pour
offrir plus de choix aux gens ça c'est
l'autre question c'est pas accessible
pour tout le monde
principalement parce que souvent on n'a
pas ce choix le hante un maïs qui serait
non gm es 1 qui serait ogm mais on y
voit les gens voudraient celui qui est
non j mais si le choix est pas faire
c'est difficile l'avenir est dans le
champ jean martin fortier marie-claude
lortie
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien
j'aimerais qu'accusé merci